ever opened up an invoice from your
cloud provider and been surprised by
what's inside
well then this video is for you
today we're talking about managing your
cloud costs by exporting billing data
into your data warehouse and analyzing
it with looker
so let's jump in
[Music]
managing your billing inside of the
cloud can be a difficult task
most cloud providers employ a pay for
what you use model
which means that if you're closely
monitoring usage across services you can
definitely save on technology costs
but if you don't have centralized
billing reporting and have low
visibility into your cloud spend
unwanted or unknown spending can really
start to add up
additionally each cloud provider has
their own billing methodology
their own suite of skus and services
and their own way of reporting that
information back to you
this means that as a member of the
fin-ops team you might spend hours
manually centralizing reconciling and
harmonizing billing across services and
providers each month
all to ask a simple question like what
did our marketing teams cost us in cloud
infrastructure last quarter
well don't worry because today we're
going to walk through how you can
leverage looker's cloud cost management
solution to not only control costs for
your organization but also reduced waste
and predictably forecast both cost and
resource needs
so what makes lookers so great to solve
this problem
well looker is a business intelligence
platform that sits directly on top of
your data warehouse
giving business users self-service
access to explore governed data
this is all powered by looker's modeling
layer lookml
with lookaml analysts can define a
single source of truth for metrics used
across your organization
and looker goes beyond traditional bi
offering integrations to deliver data
when and where you need it
when it comes to cost management looker
offers real-time insights into cloud
spend and usage
so that cloud users across teams or cost
centers can better understand and take
action to manage their infrastructure
spend
so
let's go ahead and dig into the details
of the solution
this solution was purposely designed to
be implemented in phases
so that you can start to get value
immediately and then further customize
it based on your initial findings
so the first phase includes access to
looker blocks
or pre-built look ml models and
dashboards that can be installed in just
a few clicks from the marketplace on
your looker instance
in fact we've created three different
blocks
one for each major cloud provider so
that you can pick and choose which you
want to leverage depending on what
providers you use
in this phase the billing data for each
provider stays inside of that cloud
so
you connect looker to amazon web
services billing data that has been
exported into athena
azure billing data into azure sql
warehouse
and google cloud billing data into
bigquery
additionally this block uses looker's
ability to merge query results from
different data warehouses to create a
unified dashboard showing you spend
across all three clouds
so now you might be wondering what do
these blocks actually do for me
let's take a deeper look at how a
finnops team might use phase one of the
cloud cost management solution
[Music]
in phase one you're given access to a
set of dashboards for each cloud
for example here you can see dashboards
for google
let's start with a summary view where
you can see at a high level where your
organization is spending on gcp
from here you can drill into specific
projects
or products like compute engine where we
seem to be spending a lot
google cloud also offers tactical
recommendations for limiting cost
for example
here we can see that if we stop this
idle vm we can save close to 900
to directly implement this change we can
simply click here to go directly to that
page in the google cloud console
also in phase one you get access to a
simple dashboard that shows you spend
across all of these clouds using
looker's merged results feature
here you can get an idea for how spend
compares across providers
with phase one you jump start your cloud
cost management with out of the box
reporting
and
if you're only heavily using one cloud
it might be suitable for your longer
term needs
but
there are some limitations to this
approach
primarily because of the data that's
siloed in provider-specific data
warehouses
in phase 2 companies work with looker
and partners to centralize data in
bigquery so that all cloud billing
information is stored in a central
location
phase two allows you to ask deeper
questions of your data because billing
skus and services are harmonized across
providers
so instead of looking at macro trends
like total span for each provider you
can drill in to see specifics for
example if you're spending more on
machine learning specifically on google
amazon or microsoft
so let's take a look
in phase 2 we go beyond the original
multi-cloud report
because data from each cloud is
centralized into a single data warehouse
you're able to compare spend across
specific services and skus like we're
showing here
for example we can focus on spend for
compute across all three providers
centralizing your cloud billing data
into bigquery unlocks even more
cost-saving opportunities
but in the last phase we take things one
step further by mapping tags labels and
cost center information across each of
the clouds
additionally we introduce automatic data
actions
and bigquery machine learning
forecasting models
to empower you to be proactive about
spending decisions and take direct
action from within the tool
let's see how that empowers users to
further optimize spend
with phase 3 you're given much more
power to act on cost insights
now with cost center mappings customized
for your organization you can do things
like leverage machine learning models to
estimate future spend for specific
business areas
so instead of needing to manually create
invoices in excel
looker will send a document with each
line item to the appropriate director on
your behalf
awesome so now you should have an
understanding of how looker gives
finnops teams the ability to save money
and reduce waste for cloud
infrastructure
through this phased approach you can
start optimizing right away
and then continue to customize and
integrate insights to further support
your organization
ready to get started check out the links
below
[Music]
you